so whether you were writing a
search-and-rescue or just in general do
you rely on a certain structure or book
to help you start the screenplay finish
it you being a book for the source
material or a book for inspiration
inspiration or writing book no you know
but there is one book that I you know I
probably mentioned this before there is
the that book by Stephen King on writing
which was key when I started to sit down
and do search and rescue I don't know
why cuz Valerie didn't point me to that
book but I think I either somebody
introduced it to me or I just came
across it and was right at that point
where I was you know am I gonna do this
am I really gonna commit am I gonna do
this and then I read that book by
Stephen King which is this really thin
book I have you have you read it yeah
it's great it's great it's about his
life - it's not just how it's not just
one of these like you know this is how
you write a book or a screenplay it was
there it was very conversational like
his stuff is it was very unpretentious
and it somehow demystified it and made
it easier to start so that book I think
was really key because I felt like I
just needed to kind of I don't know it
just seemed less complicated than like
reading one of those classic
screenwriting you know like books you
know where's the inciting incident
although there wasn't any of that stuff
it was just like this is you know this
is how I do it and it works for me and
maybe it'll work for you and I was like
okay you know so that was key I mean I
don't and I actually recommend that book
when I you know when people say what
book that's the book I recommend for
writers I thought it was good too and I
forgot exactly how he says it's been a
few years since I've read it but when he
actually became a writer writer in terms
of he was hired and then it was
difficult to finish things right
without substances or whatever you know
I mean yes it was very interesting now
you wouldn't think that that would be a
problem right as you wouldn't write all
of us are waiting to get to a point
where we don't have to worry about a day
job and then he talks about not having a
day job and having to be discipline and
things like that that's a problem I
think a lot of us don't think about no
no I think and also there's a pressure
now all of a sudden is like you're not
you know now you are this thing you are
this professional
things you were expected to deliver you
know and yeah I just think he made it
easy to for the prospective rider just
to just get you know to realize that
yeah this stuff is probably in you and
you just have to be you know you just
have to be serious about it and get down
to business you know and and it's the
it's the unofficial miss of it or the
then that not mathematical kind of step
by step process that I think made the
book good and it spoke to me anyway
because again I didn't I didn't think
that way anyway I didn't I didn't
naturally feel like I could need it to
out I could outline every single scene
of the other of the movie before I wrote
it and in a way it kind of started to
kill the any of the joy because writing
is so hard to me the discovery of the
piece as you write it is something that
is one of the most enjoyable parts of
writing to me because otherwise you're
just executing something that's already
been formed and to a certainty and to a
certain degree I mean that's what you're
doing when you're making a film but
there's such a translation from the word
to the to the image with actors and
everything it's just that's such a huge
translation that it that doesn't feel
boring although I heard like again like
hitch to Hitchcock is to say by time I
made the movie it was so designed that I
was like it was bored to death because I
knew it so well I didn't even want to
show up it was done in my head but for
writing I felt that if it was so laid
out that I would just be like a slave to
this outline like I know I got to write
this you know I'm gonna write this as
opposed to something that you know would
sort of reveal itself so that to me is
like the coolest part of writing is that
when the movie when the when the story
starts to reveal itself to you it
becomes a lot of living thing have you
ever followed a strict routine you you
seem like you maybe vacillate yeah it
depends on the situation like you know
with search and rescue I knew that if I
didn't get up every day and write I
wouldn't do it like it would never get
done I almost did it just to get so I
could just get it over with you know
what I mean like if you just get up and
do it
that's the math I did if I can write
three pages a day it's finite that means
if I can only have only have the burden
of writing three pages a day that after
you know you know 40 days or whatever
it'll be done at least there'll be
something done so just like it was
almost like a diet or something like
just do just do it nobody wants to do it
but you just I can do it I can do it for
a month I can actually do it for a month
now that's why again going back to the
real writer the real writer doesn't
stays on that diet their whole life I
mean they just keep doing it but I also
think that the real writer is addicted
in the same way a filmmaker is in other
words it can't just be a chore as hard
as a writer will say it's hard it can't
be a chore it has to be an addiction
otherwise you will not just like going
to the gym for a lot of people as an
addiction there's something in the
adrenaline or something the you know you
just get jacked up and you now you need
to do this thing so I don't I didn't
continue that once I finished writing
that script then it was it was like okay
now I got to think about like how I'm
gonna make it that's why I don't say I'm
a real I'm not I'm a classic writer
because if that was the case I would
just put that away and start writing the
next thing but to me it's just the step
necessary step so I can now set about
making the movie you know so that's
where I am you know I went through the
writing process so I could make the
movie and you have a campaign on
IndieGoGo yeah we have an IndieGoGo
campaign it's it's it's it's continuing
you know until the end of October and
yeah everything is on there you know we
that was another thing it was also like
you know what's what does it take to
make an IndieGoGo campaign well it takes
at least this this this this and this it
takes a lot of I mean it doesn't it can
be different for everybody but for the
people that that were working with me
they were like you know we really got to
spend a month or two at least two months
of just producing content that that sets
up the campaign in other words I don't
building an awareness and how are you
going to build that awareness are you
just gonna comment that I'm making a
movie or do you
in our case create a lot of videos a lot
of sort of mini teases and and aspects
of the content of the story and also my
biography as a filmmaker in the films
I've made
all these things it was just like it was
a production of two months before we
even launched the campaign and then it
was all the videos and and stuff that
had to be created for the campaign
itself and even then you know you can do
all that but you know there's no
guarantee how much you're gonna get but
I felt like at least I had to put my
best foot forward and do as best a job
as I could producing that stuff and so
that's what we did do you have a target
date for I want to shoot in January I
want to I won't I want to shoot the film
in January and I think that's doable and
you know like I said the actors are on
board Kevin Corrigan and Lucy Davis and
Barry Bostwick are all on board and
Allan Havey just joined the cast and
that cast will continue to grow and as
soon as we're like actually greenlit
fully greenly and we're making it on
this day I know we're actually going to
get bigger names to commit because there
are a lot of animal-loving celebrities
in this town and and I'm sure they'll
want to get involved in the picture if
it's actually happening they know they
only have to come in for a day or two
but January is what I hope to do it you
know here in LA yeah partly in LA the
movie is set in LA but again you're like
all independent filmmakers will just go
where the where the dollar stretches
farthest we actually shot Dale yeah well
we actually shot the teaser in Oakland
and that's where a lot of technicians
and people I know and I had some
infrastructure there and so we may
actually shoot a chunk of it in Oakland
and the Bay Area and another chunk of it
here but you know it's a small budget so
you know you wanted like stretch the
money sure yeah and so the crowdfunding
campaign most of it goes to production
or some of it go to post or well I mean
it's it's it's all towards production
imposed I mean there's just the means of
making the movie and you know I have to
think about like you know if we get
enough to get it in the can then that's
what we'll do you know we'll put we'll
put it in the can and then we'll use
that material too if we have to to raise
the additional money but I feel like you
know I think the most important thing
the process is that for anybody is just
putting it into play you know like
putting it because there's every reason
there's a million reasons to not do it
like I and most of it was just fear of
it not happening or maybe it won't
happen or whatever and I feel like the
second I committed to the idea of making
the thing that that itself and that's
this is not a new concept but that ended
up itself that mindset attracted people
to the to the project and it started to
get its own momentum going and this you
know you build it bit by bit
you know you build a person-by-person
dollar by dollar and you just you just
keep going so I'm very grateful just
that I was able to put it into play as a
dog and the dog agrees
[Laughter]
you